Reconnaissez-vous cette pâtisserie ?
Si vous pouviez en percevoir le parfum,
je suis sûr que vous auriez trouvé.
C'est un pain d'épices.
Allez ! Aujourd'hui dans Sur la planche.
On va voir ce qu'il a dans le ventre.
Pas que des épices.
Mais d'abord, un peu d'histoire
et de géographie.
J'aime bien raconter d'où viennent
les aliments que nous consommons.
Souvent, je me régale. Et vous aussi, j'espère.
Le pain d'épices viendrait de Chine
après s'être répandu jusqu'au
Moyen-Orient dans le sillage
des armées de l'empereur Gengis Khan,
les croisés auraient ensuite
rapporté la recette en Europe au XIIème et au XIIIème siècle.
Souvent confectionnées par les moines
durant la période de Noël,
certaines villes françaises en ont fait une de leurs spécialités :
Reims, Dijon, Gertwiller en Alsace
où il y a même un musée du pain d’épices.
Chacun a d'ailleurs sa recette.
À Paris, il y avait même une foire
au pain d'épices
qui se déroulait
chaque année à Pâques.
C'est l'ancêtre de
la Foire du Trône.
Bon, je ne voudrais pas
gâcher la fête,
mais on est dans sur la planche,
la recette !
T'as raison !
Dans un pain d'épices,
il y a des épices, bien sûr, mais pas que...
Direction la cuisine.
Je l'ai dit, chacun a sa  manière
de confectionner le pain d'épices.
Aussi, je vais faire au plus simple et
tâcher de contenter tout le monde.
Il faut de la farine de blé,
à Reims, on utilise aussi de la farine de seigle,
de la levure chimique, de l'eau, du sucre,
un zeste de citron, un peu de beurre.
Mais ce n'est pas obligatoire.
En Alsace, on utilise
aussi des oeufs.
Et puis, bien sûr,
il faut des épices.
Traditionnellement quatre épices
que les palais les plus fins peuvent deviner,
de la cannelle, de la badiane ou anis étoilé,
du gingembre et des clous de girofle.
Mais ce n'est pas ça
le clou du spectacle.
Évidemment, non.
On dit pain d'épices,
mais l'ingrédient qui fait tout,
c'est le miel. J'adore le miel,
c'est plein de bonnes choses.
Et puis, ça se conserve très longtemps.
Vous vous rendez compte ?
Celui-ci a été récolté
il y a plus d'un an.
Comme le secret du pain d'épices
c'est de laisser reposer la pâte pendant très longtemps,
on va en profiter pour regarder
ce qu'il y a dans ce miel.
Le miel, vous le savez,
est produit par des abeilles.
Bon, ce ne sont pas elles
qui le mettent en pot, hein.
Alors je ne reviens pas sur la manière
dont elles procèdent.
Oh bah si quand même !
Une petite piqûre de rappel.
Bon, d'accord, mais dare dare
et c'est bien parce que c'est toi.
Les abeilles produisent du miel à partir du nectar qu'elles récoltent sur les fleurs.
Ces dernières sécrètent ce liquide
dont les abeilles
se nourrissent et à partir
duquel elles font des réserves.
Les abeilles aspirent le nectar,
le stockent dans leur jabot,
puis retournent à la ruche
où d'autres abeilles le récupèrent,
l'ingurgitent à leur tour avant de
les déverser dans des alvéoles.
De fil en aiguille,  le nectar
se transforme en miel
qui, à l'origine, est là
pour nourrir la colonie pendant l'hiver.
Bon, je vous rassure,  les apiculteurs qui prennent grand soin de leurs ruches
en laisse suffisamment
pour que les abeilles
ne meurent pas de faim
pendant la saison froide.
L'être humain consomme du miel
depuis au moins neuf mille ans.
A l'origine, c'était à la fois
une gourmandise et un remède.
Sur le papyrus d'Edwin Smith.
C'est le nom d'un égyptologue qui l'a eu en sa possession durant quelque temps.
Sur ce papyrus, vieux de 3500 ans
et considéré comme l'un
des plus anciens textes de médecine,
il est précisé que le miel est
utilisé pour soigner les blessures.
Ça peut surprendre,
mais ça n'a rien d'étonnant.
Le miel est acide,
il est pauvre en eau
et il contient du peroxyde d'hydrogène,
un antiseptique tout à fait naturel.
Il a donc des vertus cicatrisantes
et antimicrobiennes.
Certains hôpitaux
l'utilisent aujourd'hui
pour soigner des plaies
ou des brûlures.
Et ce sont d'ailleurs ces propriétés
qui permettent au miel de se conserver longtemps,
très longtemps, vous ne verrez jamais
une couche de moisissure
se développer à la surface du miel.
Privées d'eau et dans
un milieu acide,
les bactéries et les champignons ont beaucoup de mal à se développer.
Tiens, tu devrais
prendre un peu de miel.
Il soulage certaines toux.
D'abord parce qu'il tapisse et
protège les muqueuses de la gorge
et ensuite parce qu'on me l’a dit
il a des propriétés antiseptiques.
Par contre, si vous en prenez  le soir,
c'est avant de vous brosser les dents.
Le miel contient des glucides,
du sucre si vous préférez,
qui favorise le développement des caries.
Oh bah mince !
Mon pot est presque vide.
Au départ, l'homme récoltait le miel
dans les ruches d'abeilles sauvages
et certains peuples procèdent
toujours de cette manière.
C'est le cas de la tribu Yao,
au Mozambique,
qui a une manière très
particulière de procéder.
Pour dénicher les ruches,
ses membres utilisent les services
de cet oiseau aux noms
très évocateurs.
Il s'agit d'un "grand indicateur".
Depuis les airs, l'oiseau repère
facilement les ruches dans les arbres
et se pose à proximité.
Les humains n'ont
plus qu'à grimper,
ils chassent les abeilles,
récupèrent le miel et les oiseaux la cire.
Le problème, c'est qu'en
procédant de cette manière,
la colonie est à chaque fois
dispersée et la ruche détruite.
C'est pour cette raison que l'homme
élève des abeilles domestiques
dans des ruches d'où on peut
extraire le miel sans dommage.
Heureusement, j'ai du stock.
Il a quand même une drôle de tête,
celui-là.
T'as vu la tienne ?
Mais non, je parle de la couleur !
T'inquiète.
La couleur du miel n'a strictement
rien à voir avec son évolution dans le temps.
Elle est liée aux pigments qui se  trouvent dans le nectar des fleurs que les abeilles butinent.
Ce ne sont pas les mêmes
d’une essence à l’autre.
Le miel de lavande,  par exemple,
est plutôt clair, laiteux, presque blanc.
Celui d'acacia est jaune pâle,
celui de sapin tire sur l'orangé
alors que celui de châtaignier
est carrément brun.
L'origine du nectar joue
aussi sur la consistance du miel.
Suivant les essences,  les nectars n'ont pas la même composition en sucre.
Or, c'est l'équilibre
en glucose et en fructose,
les deux sucres que l'on trouve
à l'intérieur, qui
déterminent la vitesse à laquelle
le miel va cristalliser.
Un miel contenant beaucoup de fructose, comme celui d'acacia,
reste liquide pendant longtemps.
À l'inverse, un miel riche
en glucose, comme le miel de colza,
cristallise très rapidement.
Celui-ci a été récolté
il y a quelques mois seulement
et on voit déjà les petits cristaux de sucre.
Attention, ça n'a rien à voir
avec la qualité du miel.
Tous ces miels n'ont pas non
plus les mêmes goûts
puisqu'ils sont réalisés
à partir de différents nectars.
Personnellement, c'est le miel
de châtaignier que je préfère.
Et vous ?
Quel est votre miel favori ?
Dites-le moi en commentaire.
Bah, qu'est-ce que tu fais?
Je me suis coupé.
Et alors ?
J'ai lu dans l'Encyclopédie de Diderot
que le pain d'épices pouvait être utilisé
comme cataplasme en chirurgie.
Je me demande s'il ne devrait pas consulter.
Allez, un bon conseil, le pain d'épices,
mangez-le, c'est délicieux et c'est bon pour le moral.
A bientôt les Épicurieuse
et les Épicurieux.
Et pour continuer de vous régaler,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.